and here we go with the new three
minutes madness how can I take here
maybe with many parts right many pawns
yeah let's gain space that cannot be bad
he success may be coming here huh I can
gain more space here with g4 hmm he
wants to go to g3 mhm yeah ok let's
prepared you for okay I'm happy I happy
to go down fire away it is very
dangerous for both sides here knight
takes Bishop e3 all his pieces look
strange now I can take that now but of
course my rook is somewhat trapped I
have to use the pieces that I in play
developing is not possible or not not
feasible let's say okay so i can take h7
i can also take it sexy md5 is also
that's actually a good move yeah so what
now
Jake's is six ok this is the best I
guess I'm going for when I was not now
khooneh for is a huge threat yeah we
need yeah it's pretty strong black
forfeits due to disconnection okay I
kind of understand the point okay let's
fire away yeah I mean this is three
miniatures you can play again start all
kind of weird stuff he is playing this
this d6 and stuff I'm going I'm going
for direct measure cm
okay he wants to prevent age five there
don't want to trade him man don't want
to trade ok let's get this to g5 you
really just wants to trade everything
down here right this is your purpose
your plan in this game ok
so what to do here got lots of space but
it's not so clear how to make anything
out of it they will probably castle
short prepare for a form and be quick
about it here not you've not afore i
guess but maybe not c5 is annoying I
think I'll step out of this just to make
sure
let's play again play aggressively it's
not easy for him to play this position
its route 44 c 6 he will probably play
yes this one here i can maybe oh that i
didn't expect at all also looks a bit
strange to be honest okay
i square it with night to e6 and things
like that it's double here that's a good
move tries to trade a night at 5i half
Bishop to g5 though that to show is also
pretty strong okay seems I didn't want
to take g5
you play coming at 5pm time morning
check not sure what this is if this is
draw a lot or whatever check Charlie
drawn drawn jar on Jeff not much that I
can do here madness it's all nice and
good but sometimes you just have to make
a draw-game ok ok Charlie on let's see
what can we do here maybe somewhere 5 I
could try the classical dash but this
guy is from John Cox okay from the UK
those guys no other classical Dutch they
all have played Simon Williams once once
in a while okay stop tavion
some Dutch sideline with Knight c3
Bishop f4 this is also sometimes would i
play it's quite decent for white it
might be a little bit shaky but we'll
see aggressiveness also might pay off
here it's not so clear what his move is
I'm attacking the 3m and pawn takes
Queen takes is good it's hard for them
to move the bishop so I think I'm okay
him very clearly head on the clock okay
so let's see what happens here the check
is not problem at all so there should be
seven and then castles castles law is
somewhat she give it at least I get my
king out of the middle so I cannot move
my bishop I can do this for Bishop f5
just fire here
okay he's giving stuff but probably what
he has to do here you will get time
problems absolutely for sure the way is
spending time here so my bishop where am
I going with this let's go there and
keep this closed opening up the B file
is no not a good idea yeah I don't like
to but I don't want a knight coming to
d5 on the other hand it's not clear that
this is so much but this is so much fun
this is actually not so bad I really
won't check for example check
it's the bishop on d4 is also very
active piece so I wasn't sure if I
should have taken on that if I want to
click on c3 which I could have done but
I couldn't really say for sure if it was
a good idea or not okay let's go here
for Queenie form Jack have to check
check hmm yeah I guess Queen you for one
is there anything better here let's
trade stuff maybe you can play 95 year
actually hmm yes check check him it's
not the end of the world he's got seven
seconds check time working and I
definitely will play on time yeah this
is three minute Chester chat close to
bullet check check
what fourth is on time okay no yeah
probably i was winning at some point
just by material but it was so wacky
yeah then he just spent far too much
time there three plot 33 plus 0 you just
have to move move move okay not quite
sure what I should go against the form
to get some crazy positions on the board
I mean the Duchess kind of almost
mainstream nowadays in started Wow who's
that no name let's play the Kings gambit
again check okay hmm I really was
thinking that this isn't so great but
maybe I'm wrong I really am NOT
knowledgeably at all Steve 54 what is
coming here g5 I could h4 I think
check okay
Queenie tourism is a threat here really
wow it's not reacting to it mmm just 93
here I guess push it before I take on
you for I guess
threatening 96 here so yeah this is
forced one okay one Bishop d6
queena for this room f8 this is just a
little bit of an annoyance but I think I
probably still have to do it this one
okay ig5 is also move 95 queen age five
I rookie one Wow cannot calculate that
should be very dangerous
how is he keeping the screen age five
maybe 25 was my idea then he can castle
he kept castle in this bloody position
oh my goodness no no no no ah that
turned everything around him ah
certainly had to wind down absolutely
impossible that that that he can survive
this you know objectively speaking it's
it's impossible really that terrible
position check all ok still might be ok
here white c5 is the problem check
okay I'm all-in with my deep on but that
is actually still kind of dangerous
maybe I should have taken let's take
this hey edge that suit and it cannot
let him promote here what am i doing I'm
crazy here I just let him promote here
oh my goodness three minute madness at
it's best ah crazy I'm completely out of
my mind here that position was totally
okay I just have to play look before
amazing yeah i roped it to just wins i
don't know what his issue is him in like
a resign ah yeah that was that it was a
spoiled William that position was
certainly I don't want to analyze really
in this kind of format but I don't
believe this one bit here yeah it's it's
a total winner Chang rookie one is
winning and then 95 mmm and this is this
is probably just about who limit this is
also looking like it's a win Rookie
seven wins yeah I just want wanted to
check about my perception was totally
off I absolutely forgot that he can
castle this is the thing I was thinking
I'm winning here this is winning is a
check and yeah I have the same for win
ok anyway let's get to the next game I
just wanted to check because I couldn't
believe that black can survive this
game started l root oh yeah I think I've
beaten him twice already in this this
crazy forward let's fire this one which
is really bad never play b5 and g five
in one game here we go okay yeah I need
to go I need to go edge for otherwise
this it doesn't emit it doesn't make any
sense in any case but in order to let's
at least make it look like something I
have to play with h4 soonish okay that's
why H for you can just take the take on
you can just take the on g4 but maybe I
can get something funky going him f5
things like that 27 actually would have
been would have been a good move okay
now you can ID 1 okay
getting nervous here with the f3 and
that it's still something happening but
well it just really it is just crazy i'm
not working at all now he has it
reasonably well controlled here and 95
is basically winning now I had was told
it was too bad no it's not doing that
why not yeah I mean that might that
probably also just winds but still I
Scott night at four no okay
no yeah I was it may be a tattoo crazy
check I'll wait maybe I can take on that
form nope doesn't help if there's very
little that you can try him check
check check I can check get something
back here but it's I'm a million bones
down roughly okay what is he doing here
check don't quite get it but it's still
winning Bishop takes T for at least a
little threat now okay probably wins as
well but I don't think he had planned
this mm-hmm check let's go back and see
you there we're windy a porn right check
well that's a fight I'm back into this
game and it was a total loss check check
check that runs into a fork let's not do
that hi Jamie check to give three here
check check check I have no idea how I
did not lose this game check check
amazing what wow he must be really
pissed yet i mean i was i played this
like a complete lunatic anyway that's
the idea of this of this format yeah one
or two more games yeah with black
against those solid openings difficult p
5 and g5 is a good way to get crazy but
it's unfortunately I mean I sure
unfortunately it's right word but it is
a it is just really really really bad
yeah come again again starring Mickey
blue eye yeah some offbeat stuff against
the French that's not really crazy right
looks like a relatively normal French
okay but let's be okay and have an idea
now out for g4 and checkmate okay I
don't want to see Bishop h5 happening
here and yeah 27 or maybe take it okay
you went to go into this zone
hmm ok I see no reason not to gain the
space here he seems to be happy with
this somewhat cramped position but
that's a good idea getting the bishop to
g6 threatening g5 jumping the night
maybe you can go see for Bishop me to
hear I can't take on g6 back and also do
this first
I'm not sure will it take you I mean I
could add very very substantial space
advantage and a clock advantage yeah
this is super aggressive play sometimes
really nuts nice effects on the clock
okay maybe just take this i want t for
for the night this is the main thing Oh
interesting f5 takes episode page six is
that doing much no
I was thinking he's six here to open up
everything 94 he's got clean fo
unfortunately this is saving him okay
let's go they're not easy to play takes
takes 97 hmm Jake's Queen takes codex
route chicks mighty form is 695 that's
kind of interesting I can check me on
edge five I didn't see that rope takes
our maybe rook takes in rook edge five
of the strong know what is this okay if
I take that screen age three and we'll
reply but 94 is also possible I cannot
take unfortunately time morning Jack
retakes wins wins stuff
I could defense he defended that well
and resign was under huge pressure okay
one more game I guess one more game is
good I think ya gain some nice points
there I don't even know what my top
value is for three minutes what is it
three minutes best o 2 340 that's not so
far away and I usually just play three
minutes under this kind of yeah under
the 3-minute madness um rules that say I
never play it for ya with huge focus and
my usual openings started vick lake ok
for crazy play and this is really bad
it's a ring a tank tempe down
I had this opening with wide some
sometime ago last year when I lost the
pre-offer game in the Dutch league to
lose from that opening is always a bit
painful okay yeah who is that by the way
ple right here Tullius a very good
development by by white I've got got the
center but white has got some fantastic
activity with its pieces
yea my queen my queen has to go
somewhere I would have the out of the D
file
11 key part of the strategy yeah this is
insane play strategy is really to do
that quickly otherwise if you if you
fall behind on the clock in those bad
positions you yeah you get killed the
positions are just too bad and if you
have no time on the clock in addition
then it would be will be really ugly
okay there's stuff coming to d6 or c70
and as before so
now I would like to play rook da it but
there's bishops is sewn
it's not a good that's not great but I
didn't see a move before maybe is strong
I can go too late for that might not be
the size of at least oh this is good
though yeah that that's good create a 4
that's p3 on ok I have to have to give
the Queen for two pieces which is not
great
rope t7 named bit bit too early to
resign position is is resign a ball but
maybe you can get you can get some
points here or kind of be real annoyance
in that ending and don't like to take
your horse but what can you do
cannot move anything here cannot move
the rocks am
it's not particularly doing particularly
great here but it's totally enough my
position is too bad yeah okay yeah that
will save us a bit too bad position okay
yeah I guess I call it a day for this
session I don't want to give it a hunt
to end it with with the loss but we're
on 40 minutes already okay that was
still fun thanks for watching guys